[Music]
you are about to become the biggest
brand in racing movie deals in
commercial product endorsements good
chap you think you're famous now will be
rich beyond belief mr. Serling what is
this about
your legacy every time you lose you
damage yourself I'm sorry
your racing days are coming to an end
we can only hope that this race today
wasn't his last I decide when I'm done
how you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's futile there is this change
man you know what I'd do what I don't
know I got nothing I am so excited to
train you I like a challenge
ha ha I call you my senior project oh
you're not got a sad huh the beach ate
me Jackson storm set a new record today
when he pulled off the fastest lap ever
recorded - you seen the latest record
storm inside you given any thought to me
tunic week this is my last chance cruise
last if I lose I never get to do this
again
don't fear failure be afraid of not
having the chance you have the chance I
used to watch you on TV flying through
the air you seemed so fearless
I wish I knew what that felt like
[Music]
you'll never be as fast to store but you
can be smarter than him racing is the
reward at the stop during scandal
our ninety five point two percent
way
2% lower mag coefficient